[Music]
since we're all
idiot men here we can all comment on
this this is great drake posted this
recently we're gonna go ahead and see
let me run the room see if this is
indeed
a bad thing or a nothing
or another thing so he posts this
picture okay yeah okay doesn't know her
oh there's not a celebrity or something
nope just someone at a restaurant but
then he writes
try to airdrop this woman a pic of
herself cause she's a dime
so he took a picture and he tried to air
drop it to her like creepy
that is the consensus right there and
it's kind of like creepy not stock yeah
it's kind of stalkery it's like weird
hey but like
you're drake can you get a drink pass
your drink yeah go up to her and say
something yeah be a person you're drake
and also
well since he's drake yeah if you get an
airdrop from drake you're like
i bet it doesn't say drake's and the
thing is yeah you don't really know it
just says accept the phone too you don't
know where it's coming from
red flag
and that picture is blurry it probably
is an iphone too the publications are
blurrying it so yeah that was drake
making an aubry move you know but he
posted on a regular guy move removed
yeah
yeah couldn't he like that's a jimmy
move really six bottles of champagne to
that yeah yeah yeah he could have yeah
jinx on me dude you're [ __ ] drake
that's the best pickup line there is
selfie going like this and simmons
yeah that's way better i didn't say hi
i'm drake would you look up i didn't
even get what the whole point of it was
like i was actually confused when you're
so [ __ ] hot and then she's just on
the phone like that and then she sees
herself like that yeah magic getting air
dropped a picture of you it's creepy
yeah
like so so when when we go to music
festivals my kid randomly editor drops
people but like cappy bar pictures and
that's sketch
like
pictures right i told them i told them i
used to do that that's hilarious i used
to do that to people at concerts because
you know people always record the
concert and i think that's annoying so
then i just start air dropping every
person is doing it and they keep going
because it cuts their recording yeah
yeah
whatever they're recording under that
point that's it's cut
yeah watch people are like
don't notice they're like still
recording with the they have no idea
it's just been off like fun
damn do that throughout the concert and
they're trying to record and then i look
at their phone and they're just pointing
at the ground yeah i'm like just enjoy
your time i'm not gonna watch like
nobody's gonna watch this what's even
more annoying too is that they they
think they're recording and the red
button is still like solid like it's not
they're not recording they're just
sometimes i sneak in and i just kind of
like a finger just goes
and then they always go
thanks man
dude
was she was she with the dude
i don't know
it looked like she was with somebody at
that table
it doesn't show that she's with anybody
but oh there's somebody at the table if
i had drake money i'd probably be like
all right cool i'll have all the tables
in this restaurant paid for and then
i'll have a note that says your food is
paid for if you leave within the next 10
minutes everyone's gonna leave right
then i get my bouncers to pick up
they're like i'm still eating bart yeah
but don't don't get the [ __ ] out of here
that looks like a fine dining spot like
oh [ __ ] let's go 500 meals gonna be paid
for [ __ ] it and they'll pound the food i
get my bouncers to go and grab whoever
do that is just toss them up
[Laughter]
and then when she looks like where the
[ __ ] is everyone play hotline bling
[Laughter]
hey you don't have company i don't have
company let's sit no that sounds like
drake style you just go to you go to
each table
you go to each table and then you show
the receipt and you go it's all paid
you're going home
you got to do it every table though okay
do you think he plays his own music
like when he walks up to her and goes
you hear this song
drake's that's a better move
that's kind of interesting thing that
she didn't already know that drake was
right there right well she might be like
rich and famous too we don't know
because we only see this oh yeah true
that's like one of those baller ass
restaurants she could be a billionaire
show up shouldn't be royalty that's true
it might not show up to mcdonald's yeah
yeah yeah his assistant is he might be
above that kind of reflex yeah
because i feel like wherever he's eating
at they're full of people that are just
used like someone else is sitting right
there you know like the [ __ ] channel
five weather man someone famous you know
like
yeah yeah dallas reigns that's it even
like super rich yeah we got like
channel 5 weatherman right there
we got like
dude we got a guy from public access his
people yeah well fishman man we got
[ __ ] fish
harvey okay now
[Laughter]
it's like people on their level like
like other levels
you know like dude
they got hal fishman right there eating
a plate of [ __ ] fish and chips you
know
we got famous people dude sue knife
infomercial man
chop guy
martin yen department oh he's oh he's
he's up there dude yeah
he's out there there's [ __ ] p90x dude
[Laughter]
billy blank blank shaun t
he's here
to light up right
all the stars are here
all the stars are the and then so like
they're just like oh that's just good
old drake you know like okay yeah eating
amongst his peers shanti and [ __ ] hal
fishman
they got the [ __ ] king of cambodia
there you know they got like
all these different and they're all
pulling the same move of air dropping so
there's like so much traffic going it's
crew saying like he has to look over
that bro i'm gonna i'm gonna send this
air driver
he's going to be like i don't like this
guy he's too argumentative yeah yeah my
vibe yeah i've seen that [ __ ] happen but
the funny thing is like i like that
publicly people are kind of not giving
him a pass just for being drake yeah
because this action we're slowly we're
slowly watching drake become his dad
you know his dad is just old but like
knows that he's the [ __ ] and knows even
though we're all just kind of just like
oh look at his dad he's just making
music too and i was like he's slowly
becoming like like the old guy who still
thinks he got it you know yeah and it's
like you're making moves like this like
what are you what you're doing i wonder
i wonder if you're enough because it's
not like they caught him doing that he's
sharing that he was gonna do it
how many more times has he done this
though if this is the one time he's
posting it i bet that's just out of it
maybe that's good
yeah i don't know i'm really curious how
guys
at that level hit on girls
because i know how some of them do and
some famous people i'll tell you some
guy's stories
spill the tea spill the tea panther uh
the the movie there's guys on that you
know there's very there's different
people that i don't want to name names
yeah but they'll uh athletes and stuff
like that but they'll
they might d get closer they might dm
the ladies
with just
a period or
something just a space bar open up the
chat with nothing yeah just open up the
chat to see what the they would say to
respond
that's rude because they could also
retract if the girl if they don't say
they could [ __ ] delete that yo dude
you're if you're a [ __ ] mega star
just [ __ ] let it hang out dude
because girls will [ __ ] copy and
paste that and use that against you
yeah i mean the black panther hey how
you doing yeah yeah yeah introduce
yourself maybe
hey i'll tell you guys the story i can't
name names but i'll tell you a really
funny story uh i was with i was uh
eating with this famous rapper
and then uh we're eating this restaurant
this girl walks in the restaurant and
she sees him and recognizes him and goes
oh cool and then she proceeds to walk
past goes to the women's restroom
he turns to me and goes
hey you think she was
telling me to follow her in there
you're like absolutely and i go i go i
don't i don't know
but it's probably not a good idea
or has it happened so many times before
i don't know that it's like it may have
but he goes he's like but he's like i
don't want to go watch her poop did you
see her wink i feel like i saw her wig i
think i think she was telling me to go
in there he talked himself into it
like i mean you could try and so he goes
[ __ ] it he goes and gets up goes to the
women's restroom [ __ ]
within seconds comes back out and goes
all right we go we going we leaving
oh [ __ ]
she didn't wait she didn't win
so he literally sat down that wasn't
awake
it was flaking she was blinking you had
to instantly leave maybe he went in and
she was like
[Laughter]
he opened the stall and she was just
like going like 15 like this
[Laughter]
no we gotta go we gotta
[Laughter]
i did tell you to come in here but now i
have to [ __ ]
like both all of the above
that's crazy that big sean would do that
what's crazy is when i feel like last
night took a hell of another when i feel
like i have that kind of money i would
purposely
break the rules
like like like
more money instead of going like oh did
she ask me to like follow her i would go
into the parking lot and just crash my
car into the woman's restroom
[Laughter]
i always go
did you wink at me
and then i [ __ ] the kool-aid man but
like the
he's so rich he's at chili's
[Laughter]
chill
next to the [ __ ] weather man that
race you can crash through a chili's
over a perceived wink
that's a different tax bracket that kind
of money that's a bold move that's a
cool thing you're like bart why'd you do
that he was like that's why i think
there really is like a different set of
logic for like rich or famous people in
terms of like social interaction did she
just summon kool-aid man
i think she's something cool
i'll be right back
i'll be right
back yeah yeah i'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]